Hello everybody, welcome to another holistic health hour, and now Dr. Kevin Cutters,
your host for the next 30 minutes or so.
Where I try my best to answer questions we have to discuss it about your health, maybe,
or your friend's health, and activate the chat.
So you can feel free to chat into your questions.
However, those who have sent in questions on holistichealthhour.com,
I get into those first. I've got a bunch that came in.
I haven't done this for the last couple of weeks, I've been too busy.
So there's going to be some sporadic issues with doing these weekly just,
depending on my schedule. So apologize for that.
But I always go to holistichealthhour.com where you can ask the questions
you can post your questions there, and you have a better chance of getting them in.
Feel free to chat in questions. Right now, let's get to your questions.
First of all, is soy not safe for cancer even if it's organic?
So first point is that most soy, that this person obviously probably recognizes
most soy that's grown and sold in the United States is GMO soy,
which is not good for anybody.
So if it is organic, is soy okay?
Okay, so soy is going to be an endocrine disruptor that's going to have estrogen properties,
and it can be a problem for everyone, even if the person doesn't have cancer.
So, surgically, if you have cancer, it could be a worse problem,
and most importantly, it could be a bad problem for those with cancer that is a horrible driven.
So if you have an estrogen driven or progesterone driven cancer,
then soy, I would say, is completely out of the question whether it's organic or not,
it doesn't make any difference.
If you don't have cancer, is soy okay if it's organic?
I'd still say probably not.
We're exposed to so many zetoestrogens, that's estrogen,
that estrogen like products from our environment that throw off our horrible balance,
that soy should be generally unknown for everybody, whether it's organic or not.
Is soy in different products about that here?
Is it different soy isoclaminoids in different products?
Is that a bad thing? Well, not always.
So if a person is going through menopause and they're trying to balance,
they're having horrible symptoms and they're trying to balance their estrogen,
soy isoclaminoids can be an extremely beneficial piece to that.
So I'm not against using it wisely as a medicinal approach to zetoestrogens.
There's crop, there's research that Jenniston can be fantastic for ovarian cancer
and other hormone-driven cancers.
And then lastly, I'll say about soy, is that not all soy is equal as far as if it's fermented soy or not.
So a fermented soy, which would be in some traditional Japanese cuisine,
but a fermented soy acts completely different than soy does, the non-fermented soy.
So fermented soy is actually a treatment approach for different cancers that are estrogen-driven,
because it's been found in different studies that fermented soy actually dislodges bad estrogens
as they attach to the estrogen-beta receptor of cancer cells.
And that's a big problem with estrogen-driven cancers.
So fermented soy is completely different than non-fermented soy.
And there's only a couple products on the market that actually have fermented soy.
So you would know what you're getting.
However, if you're eating traditional Japanese cuisine with fermented soy,
that could actually be protective of cancer.
If you don't have cancer, it can be beneficial for those who have an estrogen-driven cancer.
And then lastly, like I mentioned, soy in a non-fermented form,
it's going to traditionally be, in the United States, it's going to be most commonly found in a GMO form,
which is not organic and organic, so it's still going to be an estrogen-like substance.
It's probably not a good thing for anybody.
Now, if it's in a few different things that you need, some soy in it.
It's probably not going to be a problem, but a lot of vegans will substitute soy for meat,
thinking that it's healthier for them, and it's by far not healthier.
Much more substitute.
Okay, next question. I have Ben on your ADK-complete.
So ADK-complete is a vitamin A, vitamin D, vitamin K.
I think there's some vitamin E in it too for a few months.
It's all the fat-soluble vitamins.
As I was unable to get my vitamin D level up on another brand in the last two months,
it has gone from 30 to 36, which is a big rise, with one pill a day.
So one pill a day of the ADK-complete is 5,000.
I use a vitamin D. I can't remember how much of the other supplements.
The other vitamins has it.
Should I double my dose or stay on the course?
I would double the dose of that.
Sometimes people need to be able to have 10, even 20,000 I use a vitamin D to get their vitamin D levels up,
which brings up another question.
Why would a person have difficulty getting their vitamin D levels up?
It can be multiple different reasons.
It can be absorption issues.
If you have a history of gallbladder issues, that can be...
You could have difficulty in absorbing your fat-soluble vitamins.
You could have a damaged gut causing issues in absorption of fat-soluble nutrients.
Probably the most common reason why a person has a sluggish ability to get their vitamin D levels up,
is that they have defects in their vitamin D receptor genes.
So there are specific genes that help you absorb and utilize vitamin D.
If you have a lot of defects in those genes, it can be more difficult for you to take more vitamin D.
Next question, I have been doing coffee enemas nearly every day.
Rife treatments, supplements, including binders.
I previously expelled a lot of liver flooks.
I went a while not seeing anything, but now I'm expelled.
It works.
How do I know if I got all these parasites up?
Well, there is a...
Like I've always said, there are some any perfect labs out there.
I'm going to do it a comprehensive stool analysis test might be in order.
I don't know that you would need to do that.
I mean, if you're able to see that you're expelled in parasites, I don't...
I think I would just keep track of what you're doing and keep track of, you know, trying to view them.
It's kind of a little test for a lot of people like you listening, but you're trying to get rid of parasites.
You want to get rid of parasites.
And if you can see them, know that you're expelled in all the better.
Comprehensive stool analysis test, I think there are about three, four hundred dollars.
And they're certainly not perfect.
Like any other test, I've had people that know they have parasites.
So that's like this stool parasite test comes back negative.
Because it's only measuring, you know, a small portion of your stool at that specific time.
And if things can get missed.
So I would just stay the course.
That's all I would do.
I would just stay what you're doing.
That's a question.
For someone with skin cancer, would you still recommend that it's beneficial to get some short-time daily
of beneficial sun on the spots of skin cancer spots?
Of course not hurting.
I have heard that for natural doctors that it can be beneficial, but dermatologists almost forbid people to get out of the sun and recommend using daily sunscreen or staying inside.
So I don't think the sun causes cancer.
So the sun does not cause cancer.
It's not just what I think it just doesn't.
However, sun burns can cause cancer.
So a bird, so the sun shines, you're getting radiation from the sun, right?
So not all radiation is bad.
It's excess radiation that causes damage to cells that can then lead to cancer.
Whether you're getting multiple X-rays at a doctor's office, you're getting radiation therapy.
Let's say for breast cancer, there's many people that get radiation therapy, unsolved tissue, post-album back to me.
On breast cancer, and then several years later, they had to end up with a melanoma at that site.
Well, because that radiation damage the skin, just as much as you went out and you were a sun bather addicted to sun bathed and you burned often.
It's the burning.
It's that damaged skin that causes that could lead to cancer.
So going out and getting some sun is the right thing to do.
You know, different people have different skin types.
And I personally have the type of skin I never have ever worn sun screened ever.
I just don't burn.
I mean, I will if I go out and, you know, if I go to Florida, maybe to Minnesota and Wisconsin, go out to Florida in January.
And you haven't been out in a sun for three months and I go out and let myself be scorched.
But if you were happy to protect yourself, that's the idea.
But I just don't burn easy.
All summer long, I am outside.
Never.
Do I rarely ever burn?
Other people have more Scandinavian skin type and they just burn really easy.
So they have to be careful.
Now, if you're going to use a sunscreen, I use a natural sunscreen.
The sunscreens that are out there on the market that you buy in the grocery store or at a target or something are far more cancer-causing than their cancer preventive.
So they sure you're getting a natural sunscreen.
We just started carrying some products and natural sunscreen that are really good.
I haven't used them because I don't use sunscreen.
My kids have used them.
We have a lot of really good feedback from people who have purchased them.
I live in Northeastern, Montana, where there are very few holistic doctors.
Most of them don't even check my adrenal health or know what the saliva test is.
Okay, I think this person is talking about the salivary cortisol test.
So there's a adrenal stress test, adrenal health test that's tested salivary cortisol over a period of a 24-hour period.
I think that's what they're talking about.
About six years ago, there was an antropathetic doctor who treated me for adrenal fatigue.
It was very helpful, but she's no longer there.
I think maybe the test for cortisol levels again.
My question is, will doctor cutters?
You will need to work with me on the folder, email for the distance.
Okay, the answer is that.
So that is yes.
You can just call our office and schedule an initial consultation.
If we are, you could just go to our website, hit the schedule now,
and you'll go to a schedule page and you could self-schedule yourself.
It's easy.
Next question.
I have chronic life.
Would a knife machine be a good investment?
So anybody who's following me knows that that's probably big piece of person.
Big reason why a person would follow me is they're interested in right technology,
because we've been using right technology for gosh, 20, some years now.
25 years.
It's 25 years.
Yes.
25 years or so.
Wow.
There's somebody thought of that.
Um, so.
But so a right for sheet who for those who don't know what that is,
is a great light frequency generator.
And it's used to stimulate the body at different frequencies.
What's the best?
So again, any therapy tool is just that.
It's a tool.
And any tool needs to be used correctly.
Um, you could use a screwdriver to hammer a nail in,
but it's not going to be very effective.
Um, you could use a hammer to hammer it a screw,
but you lost the benefit of the screw that you're just using as a nail.
So you want to use a tool correctly.
Um, let's say my main issue was heavy metal toxicity.
That was my main issue.
Nobody just has one problem, right?
Um, so when I buy a right for sheet to help me detox heavy metals.
Well, yeah, there's benefits to a right for sheet to help you detox,
because you can run liver frequencies.
You can run detox protocols of different things with the right for sheet.
Um, but I would do other things, maybe even, you know, more.
So before I would invest in a right for sheet or a heavy metal toxicity.
Um, but if I have a Lyme disease, if I have cancer, if I have a chronic infection,
which ties to many, many autoimmune diseases,
um, definitely a right for sheet is a good investment.
So a right for sheet uses life frequencies to help your body kill different things.
So it can help your body kill cancer.
It can help your body kill Lyme disease.
Which is Eurelia, Darceodella, uh, and other, uh, colon infections that go with Lyme.
It can help chronic viruses.
Um, we used Lyme a lot at this last, um, quote unquote, pandemic.
It was, it could be very beneficial to help protect your family.
It's a great tool.
You feel like you're coming down with something.
It's, I think, I think everybody would be benefited to have a right for sheet in their home.
But if I had, um, an issue like cancer or a chronic Lyme disease,
absolutely, you should have a right in your home.
It's, you know, um, with chronic Lyme, the difficulty is most chronic Lyme moves to what I call phase three,
which is an autoimmune phase.
So once you're at an autoimmune phase,
you already have your body has made antibodies against self tissue.
And once your body makes antibodies against self tissue,
now you have, uh, now you have a bigger problem because you can't kill an infection using, um,
normal leads that a person would want to kill an infection from a natural perspective.
So if I have, um, an infection,
I would take certain nutrients, certain herbs,
let's say I take a combination in garlic to kill this, um,
infection that I have.
Feel like I have this lung infection coming on.
I take our combination garlic and maybe I would take some different, um,
mushrooms, quarter saps is really good for the lungs to help kill this lung infection.
And it knocks the lung infection out.
Well, a chronic infection like Lyme,
which is a chronic infection, not acute infection,
if it leads to your making your body's immune system,
making antibodies against self tissue,
and you take things that will stimulate the immune response,
you could actually make yourself worse,
because you'll kill that which you have antibodies against first,
which is self tissue.
So you're going to kill self tissue by stimulating the immune system by taking
a combination garlic and cats claw and things like that.
Things that you normally use to help kill Lyme,
you've got to be careful in consuming those things.
Well, how do you kill a chronic infection?
If you can't take immune stimulants to kill a chronic infection,
well, that's where the rifa-sheet shines.
So a rifa-sheet isn't using immune stimulants.
A rifa-sheet isn't stimulating your immune system.
A rifa-sheet program correctly for chronic Lyme is killing directly.
So then you're not killing self tissue.
You're not stimulating your immune system to kill self tissue.
It's having antibodies to your thyroid, so you have Hashimoto's.
Maybe produced by the Lyme disease,
maybe produced from something else,
plus you have a chronic infection,
and you take a bunch of immune systems to try to kill the chronic infection,
you're going to make your Hashimoto's much worse.
You're going to kill, you're going to damage the thyroid gland.
You're going to kill thyroid cells.
You could end up in a hyperthyroid issue.
With a Graves disease, you could end up with just greater Hashimoto symptoms,
unable to get that under control,
what it's been under control for a number of years.
All sorts of problems could come up.
So a rifa-sheet doesn't do that.
A rifa-sheet's going to kill directly.
So you're doing so, it's not going to kill your self tissue.
It's not going to stimulate an immune response.
That's going to generate damage to self tissue if you have self tissue antibodies.
So long answer to,
I have Lyme chronic Lyme,
would a rifa-sheet be a good investment, but the answer is yes.
Next question.
I have been taking my son to a naturopath for several years,
trying to detox heavy metals.
We've done so many protocols,
but his heavy metal tests still show high.
What is run?
So,
so first of all,
there's how do you measure if a person's got heavy metal toxicity?
There's really two different tests to do.
There's a hair analysis test where you take a hair sample,
you send that into the test for heavy metals,
or there's a provocation test where you take a bunch of key laders,
you kind of OD on key laders,
which pulls a whole bunch of stuff out of your tissues into the bloodstream,
and hopefully you'll excrete more.
And then you do a 24 hour urine test,
and you measure the heavy metals in that 24 hour urine sample.
Now the issue that I have,
I have issues with both those tests.
Number one,
hair analysis test is not super accurate.
Again, no test is going to be perfect.
The provocation test,
I have more issues with it,
because you could actually make the person sick.
Because they're not going to be able to excrete all those heavy metals,
and it's just going to circulate,
and we deposit them somewhere else,
and cause more issues.
So I don't like either one of those tests.
If I had to choose one,
I would do the hair analysis test
to order that out of our store,
if you're a course member.
But the truth is that we all have heavy metals,
so do we need to do that heavy metal hair analysis test?
I don't think it's a need to do test.
You can assume that a person has it.
So to get to the answer to this question,
what is this person doing wrong
if they're doing different protocols?
Well, I don't know what kind of protocols this person is doing,
but many times you'll go to an etiropath,
get tested for heavy metals,
and they'll go right to what are called keylaters.
So keylaters are things that grab onto stuff
in the cells or in the tissues,
and bring it back to the blood,
so it circulates through the blood,
in the hopes that you're going to detoxify it.
Now, you're going to get rid of it.
And point of detoxification, remember, is toilet.
So the problem is,
is I call that phase zero
when you're keylating stuff out of the tissue.
You have six other phases that you have to do first,
prior to that.
Many times when people aren't able to detoxify quickly,
they could be labeled historically,
they're labeled slower detoxers.
It's because they have issues with most commonly,
with phase one phase two,
detox pathways in the liver,
and most commonly to that,
the issues are genetic.
So if you have genetic defects on your cytochrome p450,
your punt pathways,
your PNAT pathways,
you're going to have slower detox ability,
and the liver is going to get clogged quickly.
There's other reasons too,
a person can have a hope of a liver
because a whole bunch of different things.
But those are,
that is probably the most common traffic jam
that we have in the whole detox pathways.
So I would highly suggest that you go,
get our course for 50 bucks on the six,
on the seven phases of detoxification
and start going through that.
You have to go through all these phases of detoxification,
and you really,
and I,
in my opinion, have no business to each elation
and tell you dealt with these other six pages of phases
of detoxification.
Also, getting genetics done
would be a good thing to look at too.
I am 50, 67,
and not on prescription drugs.
Drugs, no, take several supplements for prevention.
Can you suggest any supplements for overall health?
I want to make sure I'm not missing something that I need.
Okay, so I'm a big fan of getting your nutrients
through your food, okay?
So I know that the very term supplement
means your supplement team, your diet.
But the best way you can,
you know, be healthy is to prevent disease
and to make sure you're getting happy to good diet
that you're not causing inflammation.
So I don't think that,
in one sense,
I don't think that everybody's,
it just needs supplements, okay?
And I don't think everybody needs to be taking supplements all the time.
So,
but in other sense,
I realize that it's very difficult to get all your nutrition
through your diet, especially as we age.
Our food has less and less nutrients in it.
Even organic food has,
you know,
studies done that has far less nutrients
than organic food did 50 years ago.
So that's just the facts.
So what do you do to try to supplement your diet?
The best thing is through whole food type nutrition.
I like, like, greens products,
just in a general whole food supplement.
Most people are deficient.
A lot of people are deficient in minerals,
taking a good mineral product can be beneficial.
And I always,
and I think I have a blog post on what is a good mineral
because poorly-keylated minerals are actually bad for you.
So look at our blog about different minerals and try to,
how to recognize a good versus bad mineral supplement that's on the market.
And then deal with the causes of possible morbidity that you have.
So if I have issues with, like,
got you deal with why do you have issues with your gut?
If you have other symptoms, heart issues, cholesterol issues,
you know, things you want to deal with,
why you have those things that address those things.
So I like to get specific,
and I like to do testing.
So, but just from a general standpoint,
maybe taking a whole food nutrition,
like a whole food greens first type supplement
would be the first thing to start with.
But again, I'm cautious to even recommend that
because if a person has different food sensitivities,
sometimes he can't be on that.
So, but that would be the most general answer I could give you with that.
My three-year-old contracted Lyme's disease
that we discovered from having a fever, fatigue,
and people who are exposed to irashes,
covering his body,
is there still considered an early phase
for 14 days after doxocycline isn't enough?
So I think the question is,
three-year-old, with Lyme,
14 days of taking doxocycline,
or 14 days after doxocycline,
you're figuring out when this person got the tick bite,
therefore when they were exposed to the orelia.
So, the answer to this is that a person could move
from acute to chronic phase,
literally overnight.
So, most people,
it can, most people, it will take weeks to month
for them to move from acute to chronic phase.
And for those who don't understand that terminology,
let me explain briefly about Lyme's disease.
So, Lyme's disease is, from a tick bite,
you get orelia burgodorphy
and possible co-infections that enter that person's bloodstream,
that bacterial infection in the bloodstream is going to cause infectious type symptoms,
acute infection type symptoms.
Typically, like this person said,
a tick blue-like symptoms fever.
Some people, it will show a reaction in the skin.
In the typical reaction of orelia,
the skin is a bullseye rash,
though most people that get Lyme disease never get a bullseye rash.
And a lot of people that get Lyme disease never show acute infectious signs.
So, it's actually a blessing that you get these acute infectious signs
in or the bullseye rash,
because it's easily identified.
I think the one person should do,
if this happens,
is that they should start on an antibiotic,
and the most common antibiotic used for this is doxycycline.
Doxycycline, though,
a box of salad can be just as effective.
The typical treatment from a Lyme literate doctor with Doxycycline
is going to be 30 days of treatment.
Does a person need,
if the question is does a person need to continue the whole 30 days?
The answer is no.
That is just what's recommended.
By the medical establishment,
I've had Lyme disease at least twice,
I think three times,
and I took a box of salad for it,
and I only took it two days, one time, three days,
and other times some people say that's foolish,
because you could leave chronic Lyme
into your system.
It works for me.
I've had a big band of taking antibiotics for a long term.
So, everybody's different.
Of course, I never take antibiotics,
so it works very well for me.
And you'll know if you have a bacterial infection,
if take antibiotics,
then you feel about 80% better suit after you're taken.
So,
if the question is that,
can you stop after 14 days of antibiotics,
that's something you're going to have to discuss with the describing doctor.
If the question is,
did we catch it in the acute phase after 14 days?
Everybody's different.
So, I've had people that have taken antibiotics and felt 100% better,
stopped the antibiotics after a full course of antibiotics.
After a course of time, two weeks to four weeks,
they start their symptoms all over.
Do the antibiotics again?
If the doctor talks it out,
and the whole course of antibiotics stop,
a few weeks later, comes back again,
then you know the bacteria has gone into the cell.
So, the difference with a acute Lyme,
and chronic Lyme is acute Lyme,
it's still in the blood,
or it's in the tissues,
but in the extracellular space.
It's not inside of a cell yet.
So, once a bacteria goes intracellular,
inside of a cell,
antibiotics are going to kill it.
Your immune system isn't going to kill it either.
So, it can protect itself by hiding inside of a cell.
There's multiple other ways that different bacteria,
like Borrelia, protect itself,
and hide it mimic as your normal flora,
but you won't get into that right now.
But once it goes inside of a cell,
now you by definition have a product library,
but what I call phase two lung.
And, you know, those are the people
that they go on long, long-term antibiotics historically,
for year or two years,
to knock it out,
because every time it comes outside the cell,
an antibiotic is there to kill it.
It can be very detrimental to all sorts of different body parts
or your microbiitis affected,
or effectively by doing something like that.
But that's what usually the right bushy is,
is a key component.
And then there's phase three line where your,
your body is making antibodies,
against self-tissue,
many times in response to,
to the Borrelia in that tissue.
So, that's the way your body's trying to kill the bacteria.
So, I understood that question correctly.
I gave you two answers,
it's been in hell.
I could understand that.
Hopefully that helps.
A couple more questions.
This one came in.
My daughter has been experiencing foot drop.
Not all the time,
but especially at times of stress.
What could be the cause?
We are getting no answers.
So, for those who don't know,
foot drop is when person might be walking in
and their dorsiflexion.
So, they're, you know,
they're told coming back towards their leg.
Doesn't function properly.
And the foot kind of just drops and they can trip.
So, usually a person that has,
if you have foot drop,
you're going to often have falls.
That's a form of ataxia.
So, ataxia is dysfunction of motor function.
Motor function should be muscle function.
So, with young girl having this,
the first thing you should think of is,
is gluten ataxia.
So, gluten ataxia is a form of ataxia
from the gluten sensitivity.
So, gluten,
founded, you know,
bread, wheat,
spelt, malt, barley.
And the protein is gliandin.
So, person has a sensitivity to gliandin.
Gliandin antibodies.
They eat gliandin and cause this inflammation.
And you have a gluteomorphine reaction.
You have gluteomorphine receptors in the gut to the brain.
And you're going to have inflammation of the brain.
And if it's inflammation,
if the motor center is a frontal motor center,
which is this part of the brain here,
you can end up with ataxia.
Well, story to tell.
There's different reasons why a person can have ataxia.
Person can have ataxia from other inflammatory conditions
in the brain.
Post-concussive syndrome is another reason why a person can have ataxia.
Alcohol consumption causes ataxia.
The list goes on and on.
But the most common for a young person would be gluten ataxia.
So, getting her completely off-gluten.
And if this, I don't know who this person is,
this question is,
but if this person said,
well, she is off of gluten,
then you'd go,
is it times where she's,
then I would deal with the inflammation of the brain.
And also, I would do some investigation,
do some lab work to find gluteed cross-contamination.
So, different cross-contamination foods with glutein,
most color would be like corn and dairy and rice
and different things like that.
You could test for those.
So, if you have,
I think that's a Cyrex array forward test.
It's test for that.
If you're not off of gluten now,
then for sure you just start with that.
Go completely gluten-free.
That's most common.
I see that multiple times.
So, it's not an uncommon thing.
I mean, it's a,
well, you have a form of ataxia named after gluten.
Okay, it's a common thing.
For a year now,
my CEA has gone up about 10 points per month.
But this last month,
it dropped 10 points.
I was very curious to know if this is a good sign
or can fluctuate like this.
Well, your CEA.
So, CEA is a tour walker test.
So, that's not that we would normally do.
This person must have a diagnosis of cancer
and their monetary,
their cancer using two markers.
If your CEA has gone up 10 points per month,
for the last,
it doesn't say for the last,
but that would be definitely concerned for me.
And you'd want to investigate further what is causing it.
If it's dropped 10 points this last month,
of course, that would be something that's encouraging.
However, there's different reasons why a person's two markers
could go up and down other than the growth
or the diminished growth of a cancer.
So, if a cancer is the destroyed
or you're using chemotherapy,
your two markers can go up.
So, if you have a high degree of cancer cell lysis,
you can raise your two markers.
So, you'd want to be aware if you're doing chemotherapy.
If you're not doing chemotherapy,
I see a is going up
and you should trigger you to look at other things.
Remember, there's no perfect lab.
There's no perfect test.
But every lab, every test gives you clues.
The clue that you'd glean from elevated two markers
is that the possibility of cancer growth.
So, you'd want to look at a, you know,
talk to an oncologist, your oncologist,
and see if there's a PET scanner,
or CT scanner MRI that's in order.
So, you could monitor growth.
Plus, you look at other blood markers too.
So, hopefully, you're doing a CBC to make sure
that you don't have the DVA,
which is probably the most common thing that you're going to see
but a CBC with a cancer patient,
especially if cancer is growing,
it's going to be a worsening of an DVA.
Secondly, on a complete metabolic panel,
you're going to want to look for your alkaline phosphatase
and your calcium levels.
Make sure those are not going up
because that could suggest metastasis to bone.
Or, albumin total protein levels going down,
that could suggest some prominent points as well.
So, I want to look at other things as well.
A time you look at a test number,
you look at it in light of other tests
and other objective findings,
as well as other subjective findings.
You know, I've had patients where two workers are going up
but they feel better than they've ever felt in their life
and they're just not going to worry about it.
And they seem to just be fine.
And then when they do go in for other objective testing,
there's nothing else that's showing.
So, even doing an alternative approach can cause cell lysis
of the cancer cells and can raise tumor markers.
So, yeah, there's other things you want to look at before you can
have a complete answer to that question.
Now, I have to give you a time for one more question.
I tested high in mycotoxins.
What should I take to kill mold in my body?
We've had these questions a lot
because it's a misunderstanding of what a mycotoxin test is.
If you do go back on our website,
look at our blog and search just the word mold.
There's multiple blog posts about mold and I go into detail in some videos
and what mycotoxins are.
I think that will help you.
But in short, a mycotoxin is a toxin that a mold produces.
It's not mold itself.
So, when I do a mycotoxin test,
so I do a urine test.
That's typically a mycotoxin test is,
and I test high in mycotoxins.
That does not mean I have molds in my body.
So, mold is a living organism.
It's a type of fungus.
It's a living organism.
Living organisms will give off toxins.
So, if I have a living fungus in my body,
it's most commonly going to be in my lungs.
And I can't have that.
But that's not my mycotoxin.
That's not going to, you know,
necessarily it's almost never going to give a mycotoxin elevation in the person's urine.
A mycotoxin is something that you pick up from either eating foods that have molded it.
Let's say peanuts.
Okay, peanuts are corn.
Pop corn.
You know, corn is prone to having mold in it.
And the molds produce mycotoxins.
And then we eat them.
And adjust them.
And those mycotoxins circulate in our blood.
They're poisoned.
They're toxins.
They're not living things.
We can pick up mold.
We have mycotoxins very commonly.
We can pick up moldy buildings.
So we get molded in our house.
So we're breathing in these mycotoxins.
Mycotoxins are produced by that black mold that's growing in your bathroom.
So that we breathe those mycotoxins in.
Mycotoxins are highly toxic.
They're carcinogens.
Most of them are strong carcinogens.
And they need to be dealt with.
The mycotoxin test is a good test to test for.
And you have to deal with those mycotoxins and to detoxify them.
So how do you get rid of them?
Well, you're not killing molded your body.
Again, you're getting your detoxing these toxins called mycotoxins.
So how do you detox any toxins?
You support all the detoxification pathways.
Make sure that you're having daily bowel movements.
Make sure that you're binding stuff, taking a binder.
So you're binding stuff in the colon.
So you're not really absorbing it.
Making sure your gallbladder is healthy.
Use hot packs over your liver, gallbladder to help with that.
Make sure that you are phase one, phase two, phase three pathways in the liver are open and healthy.
Maybe getting a genetic test done to see the health of those would be beneficial.
And then you're starting to key like mycotoxins out of your body.
You're using a key later to grab onto things to pull it in.
To the bloodstream and then when it goes into the blood of estipose through the liver.
And hopefully you've dealt with the or are dealing with phase one, phase two, phase three in the liver.
It's going through the liver into the bile.
In the bile, it's going to the small attested.
Small attested in the larger tested.
Hopefully you're using the binder so that you're not reabsorbing these things and that you're depositing them in the toilet.
So the ultimate goal of detoxification is getting stuff from your body into the toilet.
So more and the better and the better rate of detoxification that has happened in your body, the better you're going to have subsequent tests of toxins be closer to normal.
But of course, you have to address, you know, the exposure.
So if you're not addressing the exposure, you could do everything that I just said.
And if your rate of detoxification needed your exposure to toxins is greater than your ability or your rate to get them out.
Well, you're you're stuck with you're going to be sick puppy.
So you've got to deal with whenever we do a microtoxid test on someone that's elevated.
I always suggest you test your house for exposure because if you got mold in your bathroom that you don't see.
Maybe it's behind the wall and you're breathing it in all night while you're sleeping it every time you're in that part of the house.
But you just got to kill yourself.
So she's no way to detoxify it fast enough to make yourself better.
So you need to deal with that.
All right, that's the time we have for today.
I did mention multiple times of our website that highly suggested to quote what we have.
Well, over a thousand blog posts, most of them have videos dealing with a lot of things that you might have questions.
And you can get your question to answer today.
So go to our website cutters clinic dot com.
C-O-A-D-E-R-S clinic dot com go to the blog and you could search for whatever topic you're looking for.
Also, this holistic health hour, we have a different website for that.
The holistic health hour dot com.
Polistic health hour dot com, not the holistic health hour dot com.
And you'll see all our past episodes and they're well indexed.
And you can even see the questions.
It's very well done.
All right, thanks for being with us today.
Make sure you go to that same holistic health hour dot com and answer your question too.
So you can post it right on the form and you'll probably be sure to get an answer.
All right, God bless everybody.
Have a great day and we'll see you next week.